okay guys I'm being really uh being
really cornered right now apparently my
live streams have annoyed people to an
even more extreme how's it going yeah so
I'm just trying desperately to just live
stream it's good good good nice and low
yeah if I just just see I'll be fine
don't worry guys I'm a perfection this
is a great way for me to get the privacy
I need to be able to livestream
without anyone judging me
it's not okay guys people seem to think
that I've gone crazy but that's that's
not right
they're crazy baby keep it I've gone
crazy
I haven't got crazy she's gonna cook
not dying I'm going wide gosh stop I'm
going I'm just live-streaming
it's okay just tear quit
or maybe they won't let me live sure
they like stupid
jasprit okay exactly we love for just
long enough
okay all right all right so
oh there we go
okay so they love me
anyway they left me they'll be behind
that's okay
cuz I don't need them I'll need any of
them I'm flying on my own all I need is
myself and you guys so I'm just going to
keep here for a little bit and then move
in stages so I can get closer and show
you guys behind the scenes of Frank
Gumpel signing
just making sure you
I'm fine I know what I'm doing I'm
trying to sneak over to get a sneak peek
of the crank Gumble signing
I'm sure you're okay
I'm can't you see how fine I am it's a
party it's it's it's a party I'm living
a dream
okay
is it a problem
you can't see their dicks on best ice
nice that's good
I'm okay
all right
it's the walking dead man Aaron seems to
think that I've gone mad but they're mad
I don't know why I just want to be left
alone to my live streams mobile live
streaming is the future why don't they
understand this I just wanna live so if
I get just close enough I got to get
past those enforcers right there you see
them I don't think they've spotted me
yet
but I just got to get past them so you
guys can get a sneak peek of the comp
Gumpel livestream signing I'm doing
election he's not live I'm the only one
that's live around here
they're all dead the only live one so
just let me I got a sneak
the right there right there
I'm gonna make it from this angle I
think I gotta go
over here almost forgot my head I'm
tired
the calling for me they know I'm Tyler
they're not gonna find me if you follow
me
stay low I'm gonna make our way we're
going to be able to choke see a sneak
peek of this goddamn signing cuz whether
it's the last thing I do okay I think
the coast is clear
looks pretty clear I'll see anybody here
there's no one around
okay I'm moving out wish me luck guys
I don't think they see me
in fact I don't think anybody sees me
and low enough
see it's clear clear clear okay
I'm moving I'm moving on moving one more
I don't see anybody spotted me yet okay
if I go yeah I'm at the edge of the
curtain okay fine look under here
okay now provide me cover to be able to
move a little farther okay all right
it's good
I'm getting closer guys I'm getting real
close now so if I just go a little bit
farther I think I'll make it's gonna get
a little dark down here
and you'd find a way through these
tables
I think I've I think I'm not sure I
think I might see an opening here there
might be an opening okay guys
is it
he's one of risk my life
[Music]
they swatted me
ah
I don't know if I'm brave enough to go
back
this fired me once I don't feel good I
don't know if I'm gonna make it out
alive again
fine our guys Tyler they took me
[Music]
we're good are you good
got a bit quieter this time over too
loud there's good draw attention to
ourselves
I'm gonna try to go the far away maybe
there's a way under this I think it's
maybe it's a tight squeeze but I think I
can make it okay it's real dark over
here you're gonna have to trust me
you're just gonna have to trust me
because otherwise there's no life here
all right in here
[Music]
no game Martines okay this is the end of
the circus the tables I go okay
drill dark ice but I'm still here I'm
with you so I'll agree with me
we're live that means we're living okay
I think this is it this is the corner
but I'll make it out of this one alive
I love you guys
it was a good
beginnings madami Andy I don't think
they were talking about me
okay I don't think they were talking
about me it's okay
all right I'm gonna go for it again
that's the blue boy that's the move horn
he's right there he's right there does
something
he's right
Oh
I did it
huh